President Trump says he'll postpone
Tuesday's State of the Union address
until the partial government shutdown
ends he considered giving the speech
somewhere else after House Speaker Nancy
Pelosi withdrew her invitation to speak
in the House chamber as has been usual
since Woodrow Wilson today is day 34 of
the shutdown and the Senate will vote on
competing bills to reopen the government
neither is expected to pass that means
about 800,000 federal workers will miss
their second paycheck tomorrow a career
survey showed almost 80 percent of
Americans said they live paycheck to
paycheck ed O'Keefe spoke with some
furloughed federal employees he's at a
food distribution center in Washington
heed good morning good morning Nora it's
expected to be another busy day here at
the Capital Area Food Bank and what's
incredible is that a growing amount of
the food in this massive warehouse is
going to end up assisting furloughed
federal employees and given the risk of
shutdowns a growing number of those
workers tell us they may need to find a
new line of work I do look paycheck to
paycheck
one paycheck from peril secret Lane
furloughed for a month now faces a more
urgent reality as of today I have a
dollar and six cents in my bank account
dollar in six that's how much I have
it's very terrifying when you look at
your bank account you have no money
coming in you don't know when you're
gonna get your next paycheck and you're
like what do i do so far her answer get
groceries at food banks and sell things
off her own shelves anything that I can
sell that anybody would want to buy
because as I said I have not been able
to get another job that's how desperate
I am the limp if somebody wants to buy
it they can buy it
that's just how desperate I am so
desperate Lane now fears losing her new
home I just bought a new house and I
can't make my first mortgage payment
she's not alone after a 16-day
government shutdown in 2013 64 percent
of federal workers said they had less
than two weeks worth of savings set
aside on the day before payday about 20
percent of them had less than a day's
worth of spending money in the bank in
the last 40 years we've had growing
inequality in this country and many
families many workers have barely seen
their wages and incomes rise
so that's become increasingly difficult
for them to pay for their basic expenses
like housing and food and childcare a
challenge facing furloughed workers like
Jessica Appel an executive assistant at
the Department of Transportation making
sure now that we have enough groceries
in the house that paycheck to paycheck
is is everything for a small family like
ours and because she's a contractor
Appel won't receive any back pay when
the government reopens already facing a
stack of unpaid bills Appel found out
when she went to the doctor that she and
her two-year-old son chase lost their
health care when I arrived I was
informed that my health insurance was
not eligible so I had to make the
decision of paying out-of-pocket so
Jessica's boyfriend took a second job at
night and she started this GoFundMe
campaign one of about 3,000 for federal
workers that have raised more than 1.3
million dollars meanwhile secret Lane is
still stuck I went outside to start up
my car and my battery was dead and the
money that I had to pay for groceries I
had to pay for a car battery yesterday
you turned that key in the car and you
realized it was not working mm-hmm what
was your reaction what am I going to do
and it took everything I had I want to
emphasize something that secret Lane
told us there at the beginning she is a
dollar and six cents in her bank account
because of this shutdown there's a
public servant in this country with less
than two dollars to her name
let's think about that now at this
distribution center that services food
banks across the DC area they tell us
they're going to serve about six hundred
thousand more meals this month that's
because of the government shutdown Nora
Wow I know you can donate to the capital
food bank they're a terrific
organization there and thinking about
those federal employees so what you keep
telling these stories though guys
because it and we talk about this all
the time at the table that the people
who are making the decisions are still
getting paid while you hear people that
want to work have less than two dollars
in their bank account it's very
frustrating the emotional toll it takes
the emotional stress that it causes and
this is just to keep up with daily
expenses we all know what it's like when
you don't have a cushion
something danger that happens you know
but water pipe breaks you get sick
somebody and your family needs help and
it always happens right and so that goes
to that emotional toll point you just
your life is totally out of control
all right thanks to our Washington team
for all that great reporting